what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so um my girlfriend says I open
always hope my videos that way and I
never really noticed it before but
apparently I do now that I think about
it it's like learning about my speech
cadence that like apparently I talk a
certain way they like it like my voice
goes up and then it goes down and I
never noticed that before
apparently that pattern is what makes my
voice ooh think I have no idea we are
covering infinity wars
alright so infinity Wars basically deals
with this kind of mad dash for like the
Infinity stones right and at the outset
and we saw this in infinity wars prime
at the outset it was like okay Thanos is
hunting the Infinity stones again which
is kind of par for the course like the
Fiat the Infinity stones are almost part
and parcel to Thanos as character but in
that story at the end someone named
Requiem killed Thanos and then it was
kind of like okay that's insane and so
right now what we were what we're doing
is are kind of picking up in the
aftermath of that and really the the the
recognition from the various superheroes
on earth that someone's hunting the
Infinity stones now what we do here is
we pick up initially with Gamora no
gamora's meeting with Peter quill and
it's kind of a cool moment because what
she says is that a piece of her is
missing and to talk about this for a
second I want to discuss the concept of
soul world inside the soul stone so when
it comes to Marvel Comics back when
you're really uh
jim Starlin was writing the old adam
warlock and the old vanos stories and so
on and so forth
soul world was introduced in such a way
to where it was a universal world across
the board which is to say it's a world
inside the soul stone and it looks the
same to everybody in it there is no
differentiation there what Marvel's done
recently is they basically taken the
Marvel Cinematic Universe version of
soul world and they've thrown it into
the comics which seems to indicate the
idea that the structure and the form of
soul world is relative to each
individual soul that's in it right it's
like it's like the afterlife essentially
from like the old x-men comics from
Chris Claremont when Jean Grey as the
white Phoenix meets with death and death
basically says we have all these pillars
here and each one of these pillars is
the afterlife for each individual person
changing it now Gamora we know that part
of her is still stuck in there now the
the indication here is that she's always
been there that where she and and Adam
warlock
and pit patrol had basically sacrificed
their lives back in the the later days
of the Thanos war back when Jim Stone
was writing it that's where Adam warlock
had left completely and so did pip the
troll a portion of Gamora stay behind
now again as we know that's Marvel's way
of kind of working in the
and of infinity war into the comic book
landscape and then telling a story based
off of that but the fact remains here
Becca Moore's trying to find a way to
basically get that piece of her soul
back that's really what all this has
been and so she's essentially the first
of many people who seem to be going
after the Infinity stones for their own
individual reasons and what she ends up
doing is actually you know taking the
taking the power stone along with her
now one of the other things to bear in
mind here is that of course Peter quill
has a power stone as the aftermath to
essentially the entire lead-up countdown
to infinity wars and so if you want to
check that out you can check out
countdown but all countdown is is really
just a series of guardians of the galaxy
stories and they're not super important
I mean they're cool but they're by no
means required reading ah but suffice it
to say the guardians of the galaxy are
basically disbanded this at this point
the team doesn't really exist anymore
and so with Gamora leaving what we end
up doing is picking up with group now
for those you guys who are not current
the fact that Groot is speaking full
sentences will strike you as weird like
you'll just kind of be like what you
know group can now speak yes that was
part of the the countdown to infinity
wars but it was a battle with the
gardener and essentially the gardener
was of course one of the elders of the
universe and what ended up happening is
that where the floor colossi were
basically defeated and so on that Groot
was adjusted so that he was no longer
relegated to saying his own name that he
could now he could basically speak full
sentences but he's required to say it in
the third person which is why he'll say
Groot told you Gamora would not join us
you know and so what we do from here is
we pick up with the actual superheroes
of Earth proper which is to say Adam
warlock and and Drax a destroyer and so
on and they're basically meeting up with
like all these villains which is kind of
a weird scenario it's not something you
normally seek but these are not these
are by no means like high-profile
villains right like you've got Turk
you've got bullseye you've got Sandman
but you've got what basically are our
street-level villains and it's kind of a
smart move and the reason for this is
because what Doctor Strange is doing is
he's calling together the second
iteration of the Infinity watch which is
what sorry Lord what Peter quill is
essentially showing up to join now for
those of you guys who are new to Marvel
Comics the Infinity watch is most likely
like it'll be the litmus test for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
most likely I would wager that those
individuals who decide whose contracts
are up and who don't want to come back
or who want to take a break they'll
become part of the Infinity watch and
they'll be shuffled off into the
universe somewhere and you'll probably
never see them except for like one or
two times but the Infinity watch was a
team that was created by jim Starlin in
the aftermath of Infinity Gauntlet and
then in turn became like actually pretty
long-running team for a while you had
like moon dragon you had pip the troll
you had Joxer
you had Thanos who had Adam warlock and
I want to say you had Gamora
but basically what had happened here was
at the end of Infinity Gauntlet because
stano's had gone crazy because Adam
warlock was deemed not worthy of
wielding the Infinity Gauntlet proper uh
in turn the lovely tribunal decreed that
the gems would never work in unison
again and that Adam warlock had to
disperse them so that the gems could
still be used where they couldn't form
the gauntlet so the mine stone still
worked the time stone space stone
reality stone so on so forth they all
still worked independently but in order
to make sure that no one would try to
you know gather them together again or
to make sure that nobody would ever you
know get each individual stone use it
for their own ends Adam warlock form the
Infinity watch and they were designed
for the purpose of just safeguarding the
Infinity stones that's all they really
did Doctor Strange calling this together
is done for the purpose of finding a way
to secure the stones and his idea here
is that the stones have to be removed
from the face of the earth they have to
be taken away here because if they
remain here they're in a centralized
location and they're easy to access
now Doctor Strange adopting this idea
actually comes out of his experience
with the Illuminati that was the problem
when all these guys came together in
form the Illuminati they do one of the
first things they did was sit you know
seek out the Infinity stones and then
keep them in unison keep them together
and then in turn disperse each of them
to a member of the Illuminati for
safekeeping but they were all held on
earth and so if anybody decided to show
up on earth and then take the stones it
would be much much easier as opposed to
if they were scattered all across the
universe and so that's the response of
Doctor Strange here we have to find a
way to one keep these things safe and
move them all over the place - basically
scatter them all across the cosmos so
they won't be easily accessible now of
course for some of the guys who are here
the kind of question is what even is all
this because remember for a lot of
street-level characters they don't
really know what Infinity stones are but
then you have someone like Turk Barrett
who basically uses the limestone he's
kind of a street-level guy he was
originally a henchman for for kingpin
and then he in turn got a hold of the
mine stone and then started listening to
the mines of like stockbrokers in people
like that and basically started jumping
into insider trading and so by listening
to you know using the mind stone to
realize what was going on behind the
scenes what people were thinking about
various stocks and so on he would shift
his investments accordingly and they
made himself super-rich was actually a
pretty smart way because how else are
they gonna trace it to insider trading I
mean there's no conceivable way to so
from there like his people just kind of
asking questions now the other part of
this is that Adam warlock even chimes in
and says there's something going on with
a soul stone it's corrupted
some way now for people who've been
reading Marvel Comics for a long time
the fact that Adam warlock is not the
one leading leading the charge is a very
big deal and again this is just
reminiscent of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is one of those things where
Marvel is bringing the comics closer in
line with the movies because if this is
if the Marvel Cinematic Universe didn't
exist and this story was published Adam
warlock OBE you would most likely be the
one assembling the infinity watched but
the entire success or failure of the
defeat of Thanos in infinity war in
Avengers 4 rests on the shoulders of the
plan of Doctor Strange and so it makes
sense the Doctor Strange in the comics
would be the one running the show
because Marvel's trying to make sure
they're kind of caught they're kind of
brought closer in line here now it's
kind of crazy because remember when it
comes to the Infinity stones you don't
have to use them all in unison you can
use a couple of them together and that's
what Doctor Strange does Doctor Strange
actually uses the time stone alongside
the reality stone and piers and
essentially grants himself cosmic
awareness momentarily only to discover
that there has been killed and that's
what that's that's the whole basis
behind this because if Thanos is hunting
for the Infinity stones which is what
all the rumors have been indicating that
it made sense to form the Infinity watch
but if Thanos has been killed then the
question becomes who in the hell killed
him and so from there what we end up
doing is picking up with Loki what Loki
is doing here is traveling to the god
quarry and the reason why is because
even Loki himself has questions about
what's going on with the bigger picture
and different things like that and it's
gonna be kind of interesting here
because what Jerry Duggan's gonna do is
he's gonna tease something pretty
important one is up happening is when
Loki gets to the god quarry he ends up
running into the coven the three witches
now for those of you guys who don't know
the the inclusion of the god quarry here
is a little intriguing because when Jeff
Lemire introduced the god quarry in the
famous line of stories the concept
seemed to be that those who enter the
god khorium it's kind of a place where
old gods go to die so kind of like it's
kinda like the bar of the fulcrum for
the Celestials it's like where they go
to die and then pass on to whoever
Celestials go in they die but for this
it's basically various gods but a person
can go to the god quarry and they can
submit themselves to the tests of the
quarry and what it'll do is it'll
basically put them through a
psychological and physical test kind of
you know bending reality and giving them
like the one universe they always wanted
to exist and if they pass the test then
they're given the power of the god
quarry if they fail they're locked there
forever but the fact remains that when
Loki gets here and he starts talking to
the coven the covers initial responses
like everything is at an end like
eternity is ending and then in response
the god quarry seems to be destroyed and
the coven is basically gone that seems
to be what's going on there because one
is up happening is you end up having
this version of Loki who crashed lands
into the main model universe he's got a
hammer he's got Thor's hammer and he has
the Infinity stones which is kind of
crazy here but this is an alternate
reality version of himself but this is
exceedingly important this is wobbly one
of the most important things we're gonna
have here because what happens is when
the main Marvel Universe Loki starts
talking to this you know uber version of
himself god Loki or whatever you want to
call them infinity Loki I think it's
kind of a infinity Loki I think is a
cool name
what you have is the infinity Loki refer
to something called the original
universe and this is kind of crazy here
because Marvel hasn't done this yet now
this is kind of a cool moment because
what this seems to indicate is maybe the
role of the Infinity stones has shifted
and what I mean by that is in Marvel
Comics the Infinity stones are only
relative to the universe they're in
right like you can't take the Infinity
stones from you know the main Marvel
Universe and then show up in the real
world and use them or like show up in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and use
that right it doesn't work that way
Thanos can't leave the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with the Infinity stones take
them to the main Marvel Universe and
wreak havoc right the the power of the
Infinity stones can only be used in that
particular universe and we know that
from a variety of different stories and
so what goes on here as it seems like
the Infinity stones are almost like
inability to gain passage from one
universe to the next that khana seems to
be the case and that would make sense
because if what this guy's saying is
true it if what Jerry Dugan is hitting
on is true then it would seem like all
existing Infinity stones all across the
cosmos all originated with the original
universe and if that's true it would
almost be like creating a bridge to
access that original universe because
notice the way the Jerry Dugan writes
says this version of Loki doesn't say
you can't access all the other universes
without your Infinity stones it's simply
the statement you can't access the
original universe so it makes sense and
so what is up happening is is this
version of Loki goes back to his own
universe you know kind of teleports back
to the battle that he's fighting at
which involves like all these
superheroes right like the Avengers and
and like the Asgardians and so on and so
forth and like they're they're all
killed by a Soul Eater like they're all
basically wiped out completely it's kind
of crazy because switching back to
Doctor Strange and switching back to the
the various members of the of the
Infinity watch as they're formed what we
end up doing is is the whole group is
met by the arrival of like Thor and Iron
Man and it's kind of the question of
what in the hell is going on here right
now like what is this and so
you have like the villains who kind of
break into a fight against the heroes
and nobody really trusts anybody and so
on and so forth then they're met with
the arrival of Requiem the person that
killed fan OHS and all eyes turn to
whoever in the heck this character is
and it's kind of nuts because from here
like like Requiem basically has the
power stone in their sword and so that's
what the question kind of has to be
asked if gomorrah took the power stone
then did Requiem kill gomorrah and take
it and it's kind of cool because if
that's the case then Requiem is insanely
dangerous because gomorrah was one of
the most powerful fighters in in the in
the Marvel Universe and so people began
asking the question who in the heck are
you and of course Brooklyn responds by
saying tano's referred to me as his
Requiem and so that's what I am like I
am I am Requiem and the various
characters start to go on the offensive
right like brutes the first one who
attacked roots the first one taken down
Peter quill uses his freeze gun like all
these people start firing on Requiem
then rocker racoon comes out of nowhere
and blows requiems helmet off only for
us to find out that has been Gamora the
whole time and it's just kind of like
damn because like Gamora killed Thanos
and it makes sense right like it makes
perfect sense victim or would be the one
to do I mean again Marvel's Rowling the
Marvel Cinematic Universe over into the
comics slowly and slowly no bit-by-bit
and so of course given what's happened
in the MCU it makes sense that Gamora
would be intertwined and she'd be the
one to take down Thanos which I don't
know if that will happen in Avengers 4
but if I were a betting man I'd say
Gamora will be the one to kill thanos
but even then as long as a history as
she's had in Marvel Comics and as long
as she's been an enemy of Thanos in
Marvel Comics it makes sense that she
would be the one to kill him or her or
nebula like Neverland might be the one
to take fan o Stan but at the end of the
day it ends up being like Gamora who is
the one who kills him and what she ends
up saying is like I did this because I'm
on a quest for the soul stone like I'm
on a quest for the Infinity stones and
the soul stones himself and so if you
can't do this to me if you can't help me
out if you're gonna get in my way then
I'll take all of you out like that's
just the way it is like I will take out
every single one of you like I'll
destroy you all and Gamora will Peter
quill goes to call her Bluff right
lay-oh Peter Quill's like well no you're
not like I've I fought with you forever
like I fought with you for a long time
we've been Guardian to the galaxy we've
been lovers together like I know you're
not gonna kill me and her response is
yes I will Peter and she plunges her
sword right through his chest and
impales him and it's just like wow
Gamora just killed star-lord it's pretty
crazy like it's pretty bonkers but would
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb for if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you
alike and yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]